let's get to the top five takeaways here
rod if you're good let's go to your top
five takeaways from yesterday and i want
to start with antonio brown and that
antonio brown situation with him leaving
the field i mean this has been
everywhere it's been talked about you
know within sports outside of sports
this has just become a mega story at
this point how did you view this one
especially having 24 hours to think
about what we saw
well i'm kind of like everyone else i
thought at first the first initial
initial thought was he's very selfish
he's doing this on his own but then i
started thinking i started thinking like
well something's really wrong with this
guy for him to get that upset at that
moment
to to express himself in that manner
like he's worked so hard to get to this
point where he's trying to get the the
trust and the respect of his teammates
and his coaches and then something like
that happens man and it's just
it's it's really sad because all this
stuff started you know years ago when he
was in pittsburgh and they allowed him
we've heard the stories jack we've heard
the stories about him missing meetings
being late to meetings so in a sense
they enabled him and then all of a
sudden you give him 40 50 million bucks
now he becomes a different player a
person but to me a lot of this still and
i'm not i'm not saying that this is an
excuse but i think that i think he he's
suffering from cte i think he he's
definitely got some symptoms he's snappy
he's mood swings i mean you look at the
you look at this head from bontes berfit
you look at this hit and he was
completely out i've never i played 15
years in the league i was never
completely out like that he's completely
out that is a concussion that is
something that's gonna stick with you
for the rest of your life so when you
talk about
you know inconsistent behavior mood
swings you imagine your son or somebody
you know getting hit like this this has
permanent damage to it and
you know i would want the league to come
in and i'm not blaming the league at all
but i would like for the league to come
in and really help this guy because what
they witnessed and what we witnessed on
sunday was
you know mental illness it was cte it
was him making a bad decision it was all
those different things and when you're
suffering from cte and i got many many
friends that suffer from ct we all
suffer from ct you play football for an
extended period of time you got hit in
the head you suffer from cte that was
clearly something that just made him
snap and i i promise you at this point
in time he's sitting at home and he's
he's he's not happy he's not happy about
walking off the field quitting he's
probably saying like oh my i what did
what the heck did i do and that's what
happens when you have ct you make
decisions you do things and you all you
sit back and say why did i do something
like that
yeah wow i mean
give people some sense of of how life
changes after multiple concussions you
know because some people never played
football at that level and and really
can't relate to what you're saying
well i mean just think about i mean like
i said i've i've lost my mentor and one
of my brothers junior seoul to this
okay
he shot himself he committed suicide so
it's tough you know because guys go
through a lot you know they go through
the pressures of their families you know
asking for money and trying to do the
right thing and you know you want to do
the right thing you want to get up you
want to go work out you want to be
positive but yet that ct's got you in a
depressive state it's got you saying
nope you can't do that you can't be
positive you have to be mean to your
kids you have to snap on your kids
that's what cte does and i've sat down
i've talked to 50 players at least 50
players and they tell me all the
different types of stories and we you
know we we have conversations about
trying to how do you deal with it how do
you deal with this you know but antonio
brown he needs some spiritual guidance
he needs medical attention he just needs
people to come in because a lot of times
you have people within your circle and
they're afraid to say anything because
they don't want to get cut off if
someone stands up and says you should go
and get help
man what me get out my circle you out of
here you you know no longer parts so a
lot of people within those circles
they're afraid to say something because
they feel like they're gonna get um you
know basically kicked out of the the
group
it's tough jack it's it's very very very
emotional
it's very tough it's very true what
you're saying and i you know i've known
people who have been in a b circle and
they don't last long i mean he's got a
sort of a revolving door of people
around him and it very quickly
rotates and one of the things that tom
brady said right after his compassion
right so i think it's important let's
hear from his quarterback and somebody
who continually wanted to give him
another chance in the nfl so here was
tom brady on his podcast talking about
antonio brown that's from today
it was just a very difficult situation
for everybody involved i've known
antonio for a couple years now you know
pretty closely and
you know we've obviously been teammates
and
um i would just say i i love him i care
about him
um and i have a lot of compassion i have
a lot of empathy for the things that
uh are happening in his life so it's a
lot of challenges we all face from time
to time i think the best thing is to
have a support system even outside of
football because again yeah we are
football players we're athletes
uh we give everything we can on the
field but we also have off-field lives
too and um and i'm gonna continue to do
everything i can to try to
you know be a great friend and
supportive to antonio on the things he's
going through
i have a lot of respect for tom brady
and do you think about tom brady the
love that he has for antonio brown like
tom brady is a very busy guy he's got
family wife kids he's got businesses
he's trying to play football workouts
yet this guy has taken antonio brown in
he has shown him the tb-12 and he's
mentored him he's been around his family
ate dinner with his wife and kids i'm
sure all that time tom brady loves this
guy and he knows that he needs help and
that's what he needs he needs more guys
more positive people around him because
what i saw on sunday man it it scared me
because you don't know what's next you
don't know if he goes and and something
else happens you don't know their
stories that we hear about all the time
and i'm just concerned for the brother
man because he's not a bad guy he's just
he's just going through a lot mentally
i hear you because we've seen so many
situations where bad can get worse and
we just hope he gets help right now when
there's still maybe even potentially
some football ahead of him who knows but
most important thing is is getting his
life in check away from the field so
let's get to number two on your
takeaways rod which is the nfc and it's
going through lambeau field we were just
up there at lambeau field the icy
conditions tom era tom brady shooting
looked like tom brady aaron rodgers way
he's throwing the ball around devonta
adams that connection that they have
mvp back-to-back years it looks like
something special there in green bay
right now
yeah i mean the number one seed is huge
for these guys because obviously aaron
rodgers he's dealing with a tow issue
but they also have three veteran players
that's coming back in the most important
positions outside a quarterback you know
baccatiari left tackle zaire cornerback
and of course the pass rusher was a
darius smith
it's a
they have depth
the defense has improved kenny clark is
back in the middle i like the green bay
packers man i mean when you when you
talk about what aj dylan told us
remember aj dylan he said hey man we
love playing in this weather because we
know when they come in to this weather
they feel this weather they feel the
cold they feel the physicality and
that's exactly what matt lafleur did had
a lot of in the first half there was a
lot of aaron jones but in that third and
fourth quarter he put aj dylan at 245
pound bruising back in there wore
minnesota down and that's what they plan
on doing let me tell you something i
played at i played in foxboro
and coming to lambeau field is about 20
degrees colder than foxboro that is
going to be a very difficult place to
play especially if you're dallas and and
i i still believe that dallas is capable
of going in there and if they're playing
on their level they can beat the green
bay packers but it's got to be a special
day because it's cold out there brother
and it affects everybody
it is and you really saw firsthand up
close and personal why that aj dillon
pick is so important it's for these
moments right it's a week 17 week 18 the
playoff run super bowl going through
lambo this is what it was all about i
thought it was really interesting when
we asked him i want to run this clip
real quick about aaron jones aj dillon
on the field at the same time something
we've talked a lot about
and here was the answer this was very
telling i thought let's run this
we keep saying this we would like to see
you guys on the field together more is
that something that you try to talk to
coach about hey i can't be giving you
all the secrets
we got some more games ahead of us you
just gotta wait and see
hey you know what jack that's exactly
what they're going to do in the playoffs
they're saving it right they say as soon
as he said hey i can't give you all the
secrets we already knew exactly what he
was talking about
you got about halfway through your
question and i saw just the look on his
face just that little smile coming
across his face and we already saw a
couple of plays in the game where they
were both in there collectively
but there's so much creativity that
you're able to do
when you got jones as a wide receiver
basically gets to play that slot
receiver he can run a full route tree
into rounds and all those possibilities
and then the power running game right
off of it they're starting to tease it
into the lineup but that is just the
second layer to the power running game
that dylan is bringing this packers
offense can beat you along a lot of ways
then you think about the way they're
playing defense on top of it i don't see
a team in the nfc right now especially
watching the cowboys get beat yesterday
by the cardinals in the way that they
did i just don't see a team in the nfc
right now that i would believe strongly
could go in there and beat the packers
at lamb i just don't feel confidently in
anybody to be honest
the only concern i have and i want you
to see if you and we haven't you and i
have not talked about this the only
concern i have with the packers
offensively is
do they depend on devante adams too much
because it just seems like everything is
about devontae adams every single thing
and if it's a hamstring or twisted ankle
or something like that will they have
enough with those others that's what's
important this is one of the first this
is one of the
it was a double coverage and he still
forced it he's still forcing it down the
field i know devante adams is the man
he's great but if you get a really good
team in here with a great defense and
they double team him with their best
safety in their best corner and they
take him out the game do you believe
that mds do you believe that alan lazar
do you believe that they have enough in
the passing game and maybe they make um
aaron jones a wide receiver in the slot
do you feel like they have enough in the
passing game if something were to happen
to devonta adams that they could still
win football games because it seems like
they depend on them too much
yeah well they definitely do and the
crazy thing is they have a remarkable
record when he's out of the lineup of
still being able to win it's like 4-0
5-0 something like that when he's out
and you don't really i can't really
explain how but it's just that aaron
rodgers can overcome those type of
things and yeah i'm with you man and
watching them practice i got to go up to
one of their training camps one time and
watch them practice and the timing that
they have and the way that they're able
to communicate to me they're like two
brothers that have played backyard
football together for their entire
childhoods that they know what the other
guy's thinking before they even know
what they're thinking and they're able
to adjust and do certain things on the
fly but when you watch them practice rod
it's a lot of aaron
by himself throw into buckets that's
what he does i mean he is just trying to
hit a spot he's just trying to hit a
spot and he'll do it a hundred times in
a row and the crowd goes nuts when he
does it and then when you watch devonta
adam's practice it's like dance steps
he's taking you know nine steps and he's
to that spot nine steps and he's to that
spot and he's patient it's right there
and they just hit that exact spot but to
watch those two just do it time and time
again and if you over play it okay there
it is on the back shoulder i just don't
see any wide receiver quarterback duo
that are on the same identical page like
i see with these two guys right now and
it's why they're at the top of the nfc
and at the top of the nfl
yeah we look at the numbers we see all
the production on sunday but we don't
really pay we can't see all the work
that's done behind the scenes all the
the tape all the conversations walking
past each other and you know in the
hallway and just all the walkthroughs
that they go through out on the field so
in order for for them to have that
chemistry and that continuity you have
to put a lot of work in it's obvious
that they've been doing that
yeah and listen aaron rodgers played
with some unbelievable talent for him to
say that this is the best player that
he's ever played with that goes a long
way in my mind's eye so let's get you to
your third takeaway which is the
cincinnati bengals and they have
clinched the afc north first time since
2015
big win over the kansas city chiefs how
did you see that when
you remember when joe burrow he said he
wasn't a
he wasn't apologizing for passing in the
fourth quarter or something like that
against the ravens that's when i really
knew that's like man i'm not apologizing
for that i'll keep doing it the game's
not over that's when i knew his mindset
was different like
just just that gangster in him you know
what i'm saying like joe burrow is he's
that dude man and when he shows up he
raises everybody's level and they trust
him they believe him it doesn't matter
if they're two scorers down they trust
and believe him he does a great job of
spreading the wealth it's not just jamar
chase yeah he gets all the attention but
it's boyd it's t higgins you know
joe mixon out of the backfield the
offensive line has improved these guys
are playing with a lot of heart a lot of
toughness and for them to upset the
kansas city chiefs this is not a mistake
this is something they believe that they
can do and this is one of the best teams
in the afc we got to start really giving
them credit and just thinking that this
is luck no this is skill these guys have
worked extremely hard to get to this
point and joe burrow is that dude
man i agree i mean just just the way
that he dismantled wink martindale's
defenses all those different blitz looks
that he brings then come back a week
later into outdoor patrick mahomes on a
day where patrick mahomes is on fire you
just don't see other quarterbacks do
that and the belief and the trust that
all his teammates have in him and i was
thinking this on the car ride over here
rod you know we hear these comparisons
to a young tom brady nobody would know a
young tom brady better than you so how
do you hear those comparisons is there
something to that what do you think
he was better than tom brady as a young
i mean think about it i mean joe burrow
right now i believe was better than tom
brady when tom brady was in his second
or when he was really young yeah man i
do got um he has unbelievable arm talent
he's got a swag and a confidence like
he's coming out of college with this
with this air with this i mean he's a
very humble dude i like him so not in a
negative way but he has this level of
confidence in himself and when you when
you see him talk when you see him
interview him when you see him
interacting with his teammates he's been
a leader they believe in him they trust
him and and i don't believe tom brady
was as good as joe bro right now at this
point in time
i mean that's saying something right
there man i i look at these weapons too
i look at jamar chase i mean that that
first touchdown he caught where he's
just he's a little 15 yard and in and
there's six defenders around him i went
back and i counted i mean there's there
is six defenders that are perfectly
positioned to make like right here
this one's down silent this is the
second or third touchdown
there's six defenders around there's so
many touchdowns you get them mixed up
and everybody it was one cut this is it
right here one bit right here and he
blazes all of them with ease rod it's
like you see tyreke hill do that on the
other sideline but he is in rarefied air
with how fast he looks on an nfl field
that's hard to do man
and not many teams have an outstanding a
superstar like kim because just think
about him he's odell beckham
he's like a 2022 version of odell becker
he's bigger faster and stronger odell
he's a lot he's just as talented as when
you know odell beckham came out but
think about this this is the thing i was
reading about um joe burrow buying his
offensive linemen a bunch of iced out
watches did you hear about that
oh yeah jack oh yeah yep okay so it
reminded me of tom brady when i got to
the new england patriots he bought all
his offensive linemen
audis
suvs
and i'm like you know what that's that's
pretty you know it it takes a pretty
special quarterback to really show that
appreciation to their offensive line
because a lot of quarterbacks are saying
man y'all get paid millions of dollars
you have to do your job but for these
guys to show appreciation you know and
and by their offensive linemen things
and just showing that that gratitude man
that was big it just shows his maturity
too
and that offensive line's gotten way
better i mean they were bad last year
some of the hits that he was taking last
year joe burr i mean one of them that
that could have could have well ended
his career and that the fact that he's
been able to come back from that be on
time to play week one even though
everybody was going you know joe let's
take an extra month here man you know we
need you for 15 years we don't need you
for this and he's like no i'm playing
week one like we're doing something this
year and that's what they did i mean
it's it's just been amazing to watch him
lead in this way it's amazing almost in
the way that watching tom brady go down
to tampa in his first year and put
together a championship team like some
guys have the ability to just make those
around them better and believe and all
of a sudden there's confidence and i
think you you hit it right on the head
there's a calm cool
confidence about them and it's not cocky
it's just a confidence and i just think
that these receivers these linemen the
defense even the head coach and zach
taylor
who's coached a two win team last year
they just believe that they can win
every game and by golly they're starting
to win these games where they're playing
the kansas city chiefs the best team in
the nfl in some ways
and what people don't realize too is you
know it's not like zach taylor has done
a really good job of allowing these
young men in this locker room to be
themselves to show their personality a
lot of young coaches will try to control
and ah don't celebrate don't do that
don't no smoking cigars on instagram and
celebrate he's allowing these guys to
openly show the world hey that we're
confident we believe hey we're the
cincinnati bengals we're coming for you
we're going to celebrate this division
title but hey we're trying to go to the
super bowl and this is what this is the
mindset of the cincinnati bengals but it
comes from joe burrow it comes from the
head coach and i'm just it's really nice
to see these guys able to have their own
personalities and be who they are and
just and have fun playing football
and i think the magic too of zach taylor
that's a big one is that he listens to
joe burrow and not only within the
offensive joe what do you want to run
okay let's go do that to listen to a
young quarterback like that but he he
stuck his neck out for jamar chase like
he he wanted to be teammates again with
jamar chase and they were penne sewell
there was great options that they could
have taken there but he kept saying man
you think justin jefferson's great up
there in minnesota i played with both of
these guys jamar chase is the better
player and how is it played out in the
very first year he goes and he breaks
all of justin jefferson's records right
here with joe burrow as his quarterback
so when you have somebody like him when
you have a mind like him the best thing
you can do is listen and i'll tell you
what rod you should hear joe burrow talk
about zach taylor he couldn't give a
higher review of his head coach and i
think that's why is because he's
listening to him
and guess who's the coach of the year i
know everybody's talking about mike
vrabel it's not mike frable and he's
that's my former teammate he's done a
wonderful job with the tennessee titans
with that number one seed it's zach
taylor what he's been able to do he's
come in he's changed the culture you
know matt lafleur too but at the end of
the day you got aaron rodgers you don't
have a
young quarterback coming off an acl
injury and a lot of questions about your
offensive line questions about your
defense zach taylor is
the coach of the year he's done a
phenomenal job this bingo's team like we
didn't think this bingo team like we
tune in for the bengals you know what
i'm saying we're not missing that big
game for nothing in the world jack it's
must-see tv jamar chase burrow those
guys on offense joe mixon is ballin man
i like the bingos man
i know it's it's a fun and they
transcend a small market like it's a
cincinnati team it's small market like
they shouldn't be this national team but
the star power transcends that and
people just want to watch them people
want to watch tomorrow chase people want
to watch joe people want to watch mix in
it and that defense the way that they
built it through free agency pretty cool
too that's a good good time to
transition though to brave what's your
fourth take away the titans after the
bengals beat the kansas city chiefs the
titans now elevate to that one seed and
all of a sudden even without king henry
your former teammate has them right back
at the top of the afc
we were out in l.a when they played the
rams and what happened they got they
just flat out kicked the rams butt
because mike vrabel and this is
something that he he took from bill
belichick he preaches physicality
dominating the line of scrimmage and
that's what they've done jeffrey simmons
jones landry the nico all tree all those
guys
that's what they do they get after the
quarterback they stop the run they play
physical football they don't make a lot
of mistakes they wait for the opposing
team to make the mistakes and brebo he
gets a lot of respect in that locker
room because he treats his players well
he's honest with them there's no bs he
has empathy toward him why because he
was a great player he played in a league
for a long time
and the cool thing about vrabel is no
matter how much success you have he's
gonna con he's gonna constantly
challenge you he's gonna constantly push
you that's what he does and he's done a
great job this year
right i mean just just the ability to
not panic after henry left the lineup
that that was the amazing thing to me
and those receivers have been banged up
and in and out of it but they won with
their physical offensive line that's
just moving people even deante foreman i
mean he went for 132 and a touchdown
yesterday so it's not all about king
henry's about that offensive line look
look at that push right there he's not
getting touched until he's 10 yards down
the field and that's that's part of what
this team has been and then you think
about king henry if they get this first
round by that he would potentially be
able to return for the divisional round
healthy
fresh after all these other players have
played an 18-week nfl season he almost
had a thousand yards only playing about
10 or 12 games whatever he ended up with
excellent when he comes back
man that could be tough team to play
hey jack that was an excellent point and
the thing about it is when he comes back
he doesn't have to be thrust into action
where he has to carry the ball 25 or 30
times he can come in you can get him 10
to 12 carries just to get him back
acclimated you still have deontay
foreman who's done a wonderful job and
now you have that one-two punch not just
this year but moving forward
what do you what do you think just from
a personality standpoint why do players
love or seem to love vrabel so much it
just seems like they're always all over
his back after a win like they can't
wait to celebrate with them what is it
that everybody's so drawn to just about
his personality
he's a i mean he's a really good person
you know he's a really good person he's
easy to talk to like i said i said he's
empathetic so he has empathy toward
others he's played in the league and he
played at a very high level won a bunch
of super bowls so he knows exactly what
the players are going through and even
in one clip after 81 on sunday he's like
hey guys i'll see you on wednesday so he
knows what it takes giving these guys
rest he understands the pulse of his
locker room you know he's not looking at
some
some sheet that says well maybe i should
do this he knows he can feel the
temperature of his locker room so when
those guys come to him and say coach man
we're a little tired can we take a day
off or maybe can we make it more of a
mental day he knows how to adjust he's
just a great coach man he loves what he
does
that makes sense why they've had so much
success so let's get to the cardinals
and the cowboys couple teams at the top
of the nfc got together the cowboys are
coming off that sunday night win over
washington where they just blew them all
the way out you don't see blowouts like
that very often in the nfl but they
handled them it's been a hot football
team offense starting to look like they
were back in form but then arizona goes
into dallas and gets the win how'd they
do it
well i mean you think about arizona you
lose your best receiver and you know
deandre hopkins you lose three straight
and you even lose to detroit so now you
start to question yourself are we really
that good can we compete against these
guys then you have to go on the road and
you beat the dallas cowboys that was a
huge win for them going into the
playoffs because they know now when hey
guys when we're focused when we're
together when we're honed in we can play
against anybody but the problem is
sometimes they play down to the level of
their competition and they come in they
take things for granted but when this
team is focused but when this team is
focused and they don't come focus every
single day
they play extremely hard and kyle murray
i mean it's going to come down to
calamari this is a good defense but it
comes down to his decision-making it
comes to him not making those turnovers
and him playing and just doing special
things
they no longer have deandre hopkins so
they have to deal with guys like
christian kirk aj green they're gonna
have to make plays chess chase edmonds
he's back a little healthier in the run
game so
arizona cardinals are there i'm not too
sure they'll be excited about going to
green bay if they had to go to green bay
and play in that weather but um you know
a lot of props to them beating a very
good dallas cowboy team
and they did play green bay really tough
earlier in the year that was a thursday
night game was actually the game where
kyler got hurt they took him deep into
the fourth quarter in that game ended up
losing kyler ended up missing a couple
of games a handful of games after that
when they just rested him up with colt
mccoy came in and played a little bit
for him but at least you know you can
hang with them and i thought what
happened in this game one was aj green
who was a veteran wide receiver going up
against trayvon diggs who we know well
he's aggressive and he's your double
digit interception guy but you have to
live with the risk too and he just kept
getting double moved by a veteran
receiver and aj green and it's a big
reason why they lost this game because
he's a vet he knows that you're going to
be aggressive he's watched tape he knows
you're going to jump on stuff like that
and so he kept hitting him with these
double moves and trayvon vigs just
didn't have the answer aj green had a
huge day stepping up
no doubt but defensively i look at him
from the defensive side they have to
just continue to play hard and
complement the offense isaiah simmons is
playing out of his mind he really looks
comfortable out there
he seems like he's really starting to
pick up the nfl game buddha baker they
got a really good secondary they got
some pass rushers and chandler jones
who knows man the arizona cardinals they
have the talent but do they have the
mindset
i'll tell you what else was interesting
too with kyler is that
the cowboys have some amazing pass
rushers and we were just there we saw
him in persons micah parsons and
lawrence and randy gregory i mean they
are amazing and they are huge athletes
but what they couldn't really do was get
their hands on this punt returner back
there i mean kyler murray is not your
average 6263 quarterback who stands in
there and is at that specific spot i
mean this dude is quick and he is just
like a little lightning bug back there
and how many times you see these six six
guys get there and they had them just
like they have so many quarterbacks and
before you know it he's 10 15 yards down
the field i mean even on that final
drive when it got to be a three-point
game they ran two quarterback runs for
first downs and they ran an option they
ran two quarterback options where he
pitched it for two more first downs to
go around the clock it's just not
something dan quinn that cowboys defense
are used to see nobody's used to seeing
a quarterback back there playing like a
punt return he just got him a couple
times i think that's why they won that
game
and and really a great job by them
really limiting what the impact of micah
parsons you know like we've seen him
take over and just completely dominate
games and they did i think he had what
five tackles maybe no sacks no pass
defense anything like that so they did
an excellent job you know taking him
away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports